welcome to this video smita await smita
wait only I can do something different
about the Tory attack playing a bit bit
in simple fashion I interesting is
playing one of the lines that I like
therefore black with g5 possibly okay so
some way around that probably not okay
yeah g5 Bishop 239 h5 young people
sometimes no openings this is a very
good line against the zone against this
oh it's not going for night h5
interesting ok I'm going to to do this
secure a place for my bishop ok it seems
that he wants to go for a five I will
try to prevent that using this pin and
it might be necessary for him to go
exactly a six so that only now if I've
as possible however now long castles has
gotten a little bit less attractive for
him because b4 b5 is coming very quickly
yeah of course this is possible i was
thinking night c4 maybe trying to put
some pressure here on leaf I've maybe 94
m it can go 90 form
yeah let's see what happens it's an
interesting position what however i
think is not so great is a form yeah
thats it's probably better I cannot
allow him to take and I wonder what
about f5 now yeah maybe f5 is a problem
at least that gives black lots of space
aha so it is castling long yeah what
about em yeah that's a very double-edged
d5 it looks totally stupid for this
bishop for example on h2 but what is
there a problem I cannot go before in
any case the five forever it pushes the
night back to be aid yeah okay I'm going
to do that going for player with a
forehand and stuff like that maybe night
a5 is also an idea he might maybe can
even play be six then I wonder if I
should try to yeah let's do that let's
do that he has some problems to untangle
that's clear yeah okay 92 I guess I'd
say cannot go before I see three hangs
so I'm going to go into play that
he has to take or retreat I guess Knight
f6 is also yeah this makes lots of sense
as g5 at the moment is hanging um yeah
how do I go about that maybeee for him
if he takes it with the pawn 93 that
looks fairly solid and then I still can
go before and so on but I have fun I
have some stability in the center yeah
the reason why I still think that this
might be okay for me yeah this isn't
leading nowhere is that he has bishop on
on d 7 and the night on be aid and this
is not a very ammonia setup
is Bishop h6 now that that's a decent
plan yeah I guess this move here going
for Knight b6 if it takes it the direct
loss with 9 p-6 King c7 I have Bishop
takes you 5 i'm not sure how good it is
but it probably is good yeah it must be
good to finally get this Bishop on h2
doing something yeah it probably has to
retreat the bishop now somewhere sd-6 is
just hanging like completely ok this one
yeah I don't really want to trade but ok
it's probably just good yeah still good
for me it takes with the Queen my own on
c3 is hanging rook see one possibly
Queen d2 how to tell ok I'm going Luke
c1 hard to say what's better really
how do I break through him Oh
interesting as some count apply if i
take here he takes with the bishop i
play beehive yeah come on let's stats
try to to break through him if he takes
on f2 I just go King f1 the night only
three is a good defender of G 2 1 and
step back horn takes I can take with the
pawn actually sd-6 is not hanging our
that was a terrible missed by me I
didn't really recognize that ok let's
let's see that I opened up stuff him
yeah that was that was a big mistake I
didn't really recognize that the e8
night is covering d6 hmm not good ok
let's start with this
okay um be seven or not as I guess b7
taking it I cannot afford I think this
is opening up far too quickly and now
yeah queen bee three maybe takes Knight
takes should move somewhere quick check
on b6 mean it's not totally convincing I
guess time morning I can take I can take
on d5 but this actually threatens screen
a five at the end okay i need you i need
to play move and then we cannot hesitate
much longer Queen f5s the idea should
see six Queen 85 yeah it looks dangerous
I'm not I have a feeling that it's not
sufficient but I have had very little
time when I needed to decide on that
okay
check here first yes I know 96 no I have
to start with nye with Queen f5 okay how
do I do that rookie one I guess yeah I
take it is this a maid I don't see a
maid it's unfortunate and the check here
is always some little maid well check
black for fits on a chair I really don't
know I mean I have no idea what this is
this is what equal material nothing more
I don't know don't have any extra
material yet is it was certainly you win
somewhere here but the whole thing was a
total mess i hope so also missed some
very simple stuff around here I was
really totally overlooking that when i
took here that he can take was a pawn I
mean here that he can take with the pawn
I was I was convinced yesterday with
this and then I thought be five wins
which which in fact is true here this in
fact this is a huge attack but he can
take with the pawn all of a sudden yeah
of course I'm around here why this is
like completely winning but I made
mistakes there Brooksie one was a
mistake i was thinking that maybe this
opposition of the rook and the king will
get some technical ideas but this is
better I guess keeping things more
flexible the problem is this this is a
bunch of useless pieces and I'm just I'm
just clearly better him something like
this is also saved my king is safe it's
protected by pieces yes no attack if you
have doubts a compass on plus form with
equal
terial um yeah I think at the at the
start this wasn't it wasn't clear at all
obvious for me definitely here we have a
complicated position c4 I like the idea
but maybe it's it's okay for like what I
think really hurt him a lot was this
seasick smooth if you just play CS his
successes is a bad idea if you just
place this I think my my whole concept
this is probably a probably questionable
I would have played this and then I was
thinking that it can also always play
here yeah exactly this is also the
Commonwealth yeah now this is a bit a
bit awkward it's like nothing terrible
but not not great maybe just him this is
this is in fact quite quite interesting
that that the engineer stock which gives
black a very big advantage and I'm not
so sure because this is a perfect lo que
dime a pawn down but this is a great
night locating everything he has no real
idea to attack one of my pawns and now
the evaluation is also going down and I
have some attacking ideas on his king
while those pieces are not very well
placed I'm not sure Pleiades and
evaluation is going down with every ploy
that the computer is calculating now
only 0.7 okay well it is it is clear
that he didn't play the best with c6
after that I'm in great shape we should
be five of course takes takes Queen d2
it's better but yeah yeah of course I
thought that I just win yeah and this is
why I took but of course castles is much
better yeah it allows him to take but
here at least my rook is playing and I
don't have any problem I just have an
attack IAM Compeyson plus 3.7
it had the Whydah tech is is just too
strong here on the dark squares
especially yeah this was a
miscalculation and this led to trouble
now it gets very messy yeah b6 and now I
be searching and now I took on d5 queen
bee three is the best and winds yeah I
had this hunch but I was not sure I
wasn't sure I wasn't thinking he takes
Knight takes bishop b6 and I wasn't sure
that I'm winning here check but 93 is
winning for white with this idea I know
I couldn't I couldn't calculate that
sorry that's good for white computer is
giving that but no I didn't see it this
is why I went here and thought Queen 85
might be might be a solution but it's
probably not sufficient 96 is defending
and black wins yeah yeah very very
tricky still here cat check check and
check and no Knight b6 is winning my arm
I don't I don't see it yet check how is
this winning check our Bishop takes this
made ok made on be eight ok I didn't see
that ok check in DIC hopes not that one
I didn't see that me this wasn't made
yeah I didn't have much time somehow the
clock times are not visible here but
yeah yeah so I had a whinny actually
yeah whatever a very complicated game
yeah thanks thanks for watching